what's up everyone I'm ninja I'm here to
answer all your questions about
fortnight on Twitter this is for night
support you should Murray zero three
zero one asks major so I'm trying to
learn how to play with mouse and
keyboard on Forna and I was wondering
what control setup do you use or prefer
what control setup I don't really think
there is a control setup for mouse and
keyboard I'm just going to tell you what
my key events are right now off the rim
so shift is my pyramid I've already
named because that's how I obviously
have shift as something else
so definitely enable autorun q is my
platform and my to side mouse buttons
are my wall on my ramp which are
arguably the most important building key
binds so if you have a mouse highly
recommend getting a mouse with two or
three buttons on it and make sure you
map two of your building options to your
mouse buttons this question is from fork
buttons at twitch work once says you can
be good at for tonight but you'll never
be good enough how do you compete with
people who have over half a month of
in-game time that's legit 16 days of
your life hashtag for tonight I mean
you're not going to be better than those
players you know what I mean I mean it's
one of those thing you just kind of have
to accept that right I mean like if I'm
a basketball player and I practice one
hour a day and LeBron plays 10 hours 12
hours a day because it's like it's his
job and it's what you know I can't
complain about how he's gonna be better
than me when he has all day to play you
mean it's one of those things where it's
just like dude it's just it's the way of
the road at fuzzy monster with a three
as the e says at four net gaming
question how do you shoot down a loot
carrier from 50 meters on mobile they
fall out of render distance hashtag help
me at hashtag support hashtag burn
hashtag challenge hashtag no can do
maybe a little less hashtags I don't
think you do anything about that I think
it's just you know stop playing mobili
and get an Xbox or a PC to fix that
issue fuzzy but I know that's not the
answer that you want
unfortunately there's no answer that I
can provide you know what let me just
give a call a quick call to to Epic
Games and see if they can patch that for
you though
see ball official asks what's the best
landing spot for competitive
for tonight first of all you need to
know who you're playing against if
there's just gonna be random tournaments
and you don't know exactly who is gonna
get in your lobbies I think that you
want to just go with what is going to be
the least contested that will get you
the most loot don't go for the heavily
contested unless you are truly the best
player in the game
someone glands and gets a better weapon
than you and just ruins your tournament
it's really unfortunate because you're
leaning at a heavy contested spot i J
Gemini says so I suck a fortnight quick
editing / building I watch people build
a Hollywood mansions in five seconds
flat while taking I'm taking five
minutes to do an IV any advice with a
building / editing on and out just sit
and creative for 30 minutes a day in the
mornings and at nights and just practice
your building it's that easy just sit
there and just build listen to some
music and just crank out your 90s man
you will learn you will perfect it I
promise you it's exactly what I had to
do when I when I started falling off
building wise and editing wise I just
hadn't creative and practice him and you
got to work for it I know you're looking
for a quick easy tip or something that
is just going to make you improve
immediately and that doesn't exist build
forever so that you can put down a wall
and then you just practice your editing
and your honor and your editing and your
on editing over and over again rinse
repeat
oh that hillbilly run amok says how does
anyone play in a random squad in hash
tag fortnight I'm just barely above
being a bot and I rarely get in squads
that outlast me and it's more than six
years old this is an interesting
question
but I definitely know that there are a
lot of younger kids that do squad Phil
Hill belay my advice to you would be to
do some squad fills and try to find
people who aren't 6 years old and
whenever you do get those teammates in
your game try to you know connect with
them add them and start running games
with them and then eventually you're
gonna build up a squad of people that
you can game with and not two squad
fills with that's what I did back in the
day in Halo 2 when I was I mean this is
like 10 12 13 years ago maybe more 15
years ago I needed to play a team
hardcore or matchmaking with other
people so I would just go in and once I
found someone who I kind of connected
with I'd be like yo man you're good you
want to run and then BOOM they go try it
out mister Appy gaming says what is your
main skin in fortnight there's a female
ninja skin in the game that's pretty
dope I think that I use her the most at
Galaxy shadow GG
does anyone know what the symbol means
on for tonight dude I literally just
asked this question I was doing squad
fills the other day I don't know I don't
know what that means
it's like it's just a globe I think it
might mean that someone maybe from
another server is playing on a server
that they shouldn't be playing on so
they just have a globe icon III don't
know what that means it's not mobile it
kind of looks like a controller it might
be the new ps4 your guess is as good as
mine man but it's definitely not PC and
I don't think it's Xbox we have a
question from mr. C's celeb Q's said at
ninja how do you get so good at playing
for night from Jaden age 9 that's a
really good question I've been playing
video games my entire life I'm 28 years
old and you learn a lot about different
gaming play styles as you play different
games and honestly I just put the time
in my entire life to be good at video
games the more you play the better
you're going to get and when you do play
I actually try to improve your game
there are two ways you can play video
games you can play casually or you can
play competitively and if you're just
playing casually and you're messing
around and you're landing the same spots
and you're farming the same way and
you're and you use the same guns all the
time and you never change anything and
you never actually try to improve you're
not going to improve right so you need
to honestly actively work on C you know
you're shooting you're building and in
your knowledge of the map and rotating
and things like that so yeah put the
time in practice hard and actively try
to improve at crawley 4 asks hello Mike
can you tell me how to improve mine
before night please question mark
crawling face for me with any
sensitivity or any aiming issues what
you want to do is you want to start at a
lower sensitivity right if you really
can't just hit you can't hit just lower
your sensitivity and you won't be able
to miss literally it'll be too so slow
that you should be hitting everything
that you're having at when you are
eliminated because your aim is to slow
you bump it up just a little bit then
once you've moved it up a little bit
take a little bit of getting used to but
then once you get eliminated again
because your aim is to slow you bump it
up a little bit and eventually gonna
keep doing this gonna keep going back
and forth until you find the perfect
medium you're finally got a good
sensitivity where you're now your aim is
pretty solid and you're no longer
getting eliminated because your
sensitivity is too slow it's a lot
easier to go from down up then to go
from an incredibly high sensitivity and
work your way
so try it out let me know at modded
potato asks what's your favorite for
night loadout if you play if you don't
that's fine here's mine for me my
favorite loadout has got to be the
flapjack II the flapjack you tackling in
the black and white with the chrono
contrail and also the same glider that
you have the pixel gliders definitely
are my favorites good job good taste at
what you do as she says what is most
important in four night mechanics or
game sense good question they're both
important you need to focus on them both
I think your game sense will let you
live and last longer in your lobbies
however mechanics are going to be how
you win those games you cannot win a
game solely off of game sense or you
will win less games so focus on both I
at little Louie so asks if I want to
play a hashtag for Nate just to chill
with the friends what do I have to do
play team rumble oh wait is there skill
based matchmaking a team Rumble too at
fortnight game little Louie so I feel
your pain here man and team Rumble is
definitely going to be the chillest
playlist but also I mean if you're
playing with your friends and you're
just chilling shouldn't you be able to
play squats and just like I mean it's
like how good are you I guess
but I understand what you're saying man
I don't agree with the skill based
matchmaking it does make the it doesn't
make the lobbies a lot sweaty er skill
based matchmaking right now is basically
adding longer queues you're playing
against tougher players if you're a good
player and it's basically turning into
arena without syphon mode and that's
kind of what arena is for is for those
competitive and sweaty matches only time
will tell man ah I fire monkey says what
strats to use in fortnight for me I hide
under stairs and ambushes like the true
bot that I am that's the beautiful thing
about 40 minutes you can play however
you want you want a bush camp if you
want to hide under stairs you can do
that I still highly recommend learning
how to build and learning how to shoot
so that when you do get in situations
where someone finds you under those
stairs you can win those fights so our
next and final question comes from not
Kai
so what is the best shotgun for tonight
it's a great question deed alright the
answer is they're all good the pump
shotgun is great if you if you have an
SMG and an AR and but if you only have
like an infantry rifle and a sniper
rifle you don't really have a spray gun
you need a shotgun this gonna shoot
faster which is where the tack shop gun
comes in bro so it's all depends on your
play style what do you like do you want
to be able to one pump someone you want
to shoot multiple shotgun shots if you
miss one figure it out feel it out I
personally love the pump shotgun aren't
everyone that is uh that is it for today
thank you guys for all your questions
and I hope you guys keep enjoying
fortnight thanks for watching
[Music]